hello everyone and welcome to the
coronavirus webinar series produced by
Lavery's today's webinar title is
laboratory diagnosis of Luhan SARS
Co v2 infections current status I am
Anton a saucedo of lab routes and I will
be your moderator for today's event now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to environed everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker speaker dr. eua
tang dr. Tang is currently the China
chief medical officer of Cepheid at the
Danaher diagnostic platform in Shanghai
he obtained his medical training from
Fudan University Shanghai School of
Medicine and his PhD in microbiology and
immunology from Vanderbilt University
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Tang you may now
begin your presentation thank you and
see me not for your kind of touchy and
irritation hi everyone thank you for
joining us today I would like to share
with you the current status of the
portrait diagnosis of sus over to
invention
most of the data as you can imagine are
come from men in China so here is my
disclosure
I'll see now I am an employee of seventh
the company produce the expert Express
Sask over two tests which are we are
briefly mentioned during my talk so for
the next about 40 minutes
I will talk about the laboratory
diagnosis of SAS comer to infection
here's the outline i will first cover
definition and introductions then i will
folks mostly are the and the battery
diagnosis there are three different
aspects the first one is pre-analytical
seven is analytical then the last will
be post analytical after that i will
hopefully have time to give yourself
future direction so as you know the the
name and also the disease by not going
on here for the new tornavoz infection
or the break is a pig depending okay so
the very beginning as we know all this
virus also original farm coming from
Wuhan China in de 2019 so people started
using hoo-ha cover then come 290 2019
almost 0 V then come to human color the
19 but eventually the you know our
special so called the international
committee on taxonomy of virus ITC V
finally recorded the SARS cover 2 so
that stands for severe acute respiratory
since syndrome coronavirus
till then the man that for the disease
and publisher finally decided hard coded
19 so for the for the convening of the
talk today I will keep using the SARS
over to as the meteorology the course or
the
Varis ma'am so as you know the Sask over
to Loras is a member of carnivores
family is also called her la Vidya and
the verse is not very new to us as we
all know it is start probably up to
nineteen thirties at that time people
started to isolate or recover the virus
of far worse then did not get attention
- mm sorry chi or 1960s that the two
virus wow this is a to the 90 the other
ones they the ml 43 they were
simultaneously isolated from humans in
the UK and Ewing in the u.s. so that
start from the people name the virus
hearted of us the corollaries because
their spike that stick on the surface of
the virus that had some kind of crown
structure so at that time people didn't
get a bit attention because this virus
on cause very mind human respiratory
tract infections until 2002 as you know
that time a huge outbreak of SARS that
cause of the thousands of death so
people start getting attention about a
human carnivores then of course later on
in 2012 there's another big carnivals
Commerce that had the infection cause it
happened in Midwest area that also
caused a lot of deaths and of course now
we have a huge condemning going on in
our world this is it you know the comet
19 which caused our SAS table to Mars
and as you know if you could give a
detail about the Texan army and all this
severe
cars that appearance to the genes-- beta
of the carnivores family so the beta
Janice Mars is bad okay and for the
interest of me a time I only good a
little bit about the molecular biology
of cars that you know can make my talk
later are easier so as you know the
economist is enveloped virus so which is
a good that means you know bolster the
agent we can't use can use it accurate
like a hall can easily cured in the
environment so but it is a positive
sense our neighbors so they are very
feebly resistance when you're there in
the environment if you don't kill them
then of course there are so many genes
or proteins that can be produced by this
virus um the most important things are
listed here there have been quite a fear
of open reading frame our genes or
region that of people can use it for a
prime design while them otherwise the
hemagglutinin esterase RG which is a
very very very specific to the Sask over
to gene so people used to use this gene
to design primer for specific detection
of SAS comer to and they also another
very important gene that's the service
or spike gene so as you know this is the
gene that encodes the protein that stick
on the surface of the virus that's so
called you know that's what carnival's
them come from so this gene or the
protein produced the anybody will be
protective of our body so that's also
the the energy that people has been
focused on for vaccine production then
the other the other important thing
about this surface protein is area
source
pants to our human you know who sells on
the surface through the so-called
receptor that's what we caught as to so
this is the gene you know associated
with I mean protein associate with party
to our surveys and getting to ourselves
and in fact to ourselves and of course
again there anybody will produce against
the gene where a protein will be
protective so in addition to those
things I just mentioned there are also
several other regions also very
important like ml of gene like a
transmembrane and nuclear caps G the ng
and of course a special enzyme carried
by the virus called
RNA dependent RNA polymerase or Rd RPG
those are all the genes that people has
been used to design their primers for
molecular detection of carnivals so now
we come to the laboratory diagnosis part
of the carnivores or the sauce come to
you by infection so just like every
etiology diagnosis a procedure you can
divide them into three different portion
the first one is a pre any vehicle that
means that you get a specimen collected
and transport to the lab and processed
then of course what's the many happening
lab is that we start to use a method if
an energy test or anybody test or
molecular tests then we test the
specimen then we generate the results so
that's an immediate part then we come to
the positive part that means when the
result get produced we start interpret
data and report the results to the
physicians and this is of course time
involved a lot of lab commission
communication so now we talk about the
pre-analytical part that are important
for the carnivores
so as you can see the most important
thing is the specimen type so because
this is a respiratory tract infection so
yes so to crack the respiratory specimen
specimen are important so we're talking
about the upper respiratory specimens
that including nestled or oral
pharyngeal swab specimens then Loras
Patrice specimens like sputum like
lavage specimens then of course we laid
out we also we know that our cells are
getting into our GI tract so we also
collect rectal swab specimens and for
the other type of tests like anybody
testing serology tests we also collect
the blood and we've got a serum or
plasma specimen for additional testing
so the very important things about the
specimen type is I need to point out
that the Y is the nests of fungus Bob
specimen so that means you collect
special through your nerves okay then
the other specimens are oral fine you're
strong like put in a q-tip through your
mouth and get to your fangio places
so those specimen phenotypes are very
different
okay so as you can see from this data
published preparation in you know noon
general medicine in JAMA and that
actually in China
so far most specimen unfortunate crappy
different patients are all also up
that's what I indicate here is called
fangio so are it's really all of our
just one yeah in contrast the special
cratis your nasal the cotton penis
called nasal swab is actually a mess of
value so our specimen is very limited
but what's the bad about all found your
swab specimen there are two problems
okay the first problem is you you know
you you have when you credit the oil or
find yourself specimen you have to sit
front of the patients so as you can
imagine then you have to keep a very
short distance from the patients then
the patient's mouth has to be open
widely so you can get the right spot so
that creates a same thing show and of
course there is no intrinsic insu called
a QC step
so it's also pacer it's only based on
the practice hearts and you are only
people you know if you crab the right
point because sometimes when you just
put them near the q-tips near the
patients even don't touch anything here
the patient start to cough then you
immediate stop so actually it didn't
collect any specimen so that's the
problem of the you know o P para when
you do the nests or find yourself
specimen as you know when you through
the nose you have very small window back
error
the only time you know you probably
didn't get it deep deep enough to the
specimen a site however as soon as if
the patient feeling uneasy and you know
you have swap probably reach the right
place it as indicated in the figure
there's you know in the picture there's
a line red line there okay so of course
together the the quality good quality of
specimen of the Anessa finest valve you
have to you know insert deep enough stay
there long enough then after you have
the screw kind of a three time three
cycles then you get the right specimen
because that is a very very hard to get
you know correct specimens from patients
so nowadays you know a group people from
Hong Kong USA they start to use the
saliva specimens as you know which is
very very easy
so from their study published in
clinical infectious disease now later
are also publishing more data on
said infection these indicate ya Salam
especial probably a good type of a
specimen to use the early stage of
infection as you can see here yeah 11 of
12 patient that was tested positive and
the good thing is the actually the
saliva the viral load in saliva came in
you know slow down then at a later stage
of the clinical course so then next wise
we already really talking about the
specimen safety so when you crack the
specimens specimens you need to make
sure that avoid the aerosol formation so
for example if you have to centrifuge
your blood to get a serum specimen as
indicated in the figure you have to you
know addition to cover the centrifuge
you have to use this so-called attempt
to cover in the middle as you can see
that so those are the way to make sure
you know when you stop the centrifuge
you open the door then then you will
cover the cover then you will make sure
every storm'll and stay a couple minutes
before you open them to cover that so
that way aerosol formation will be
stopped and the other ways the people
has been doing in China is to inactivate
specimen use 56 degree or higher for 15
to 30 minutes so so far the data
indicate this is probably not very good
for the for the specimen that had
evolved lower burrowed they no see those
in activation temperature that you know
there will probably result in false
negative results so another way to do
this is to use the so-called allies as a
buffer you add that into the transport
medium as you know the lysis buffer is
something include a high concentration
of warning
which you can one stabilize the I'm a
then the super is again inactivated
virus in activity so those are the way
people started to do in China hopefully
that will be doing there's all the world
as well okay so that's the a pre
animated apart so now we come to the
animated part but so that this is the
place I wear many to talk about the
masseter so far will have been used for
a detection of the sauce covert to
viruses so the first of all of course
p.m. as you can see this is a beautiful
picture of the SAS Cobra two
so you know from me am picture it looks
beautiful but this is very ugly
you know these so viruses that are
causing a lot of problem in there but
what's the problem here okay it looks
like you know you can directly identify
them morphology but the problem is in
the lab you needed across a very high
title of this thing so as you can see
here we need about a minion borrow
particles before can see it so right now
we limit this ambassador in a research
lab and and another problem of the yen
is you've only identified to the family
level so you can see this is yeah you
saw it you can see it is cars are party
to not know is that you know is a
sarcoma to or some work bars all regular
classic carnivores so of course of that
then people start using culture so
culture still remains the gold standard
of you know the carnivores detection and
the beauty about the culture is yeah you
can get life bars then you can do
further work like you know generate the
vaccine you know produces drugs and so
on so forth but for the time now sir
the culture method is not used routinely
because first it takes a long time
seven you have to do this in the PSL by
Septon level three level so that's very
very hard are for both of the hospital
labs then of course the next one data
people has been thinking this is a rapid
engine test so here as you can see this
is a paper published just a publishing
pre print that means it has not been
peer reviewed yet
this is massive a very quick immune
tomographic I say that targets the
nuclear capsid protein can be done in
ten minutes as you can see so far they
are crammed they have a sensitivity up
from 6-8 to 98% special about a hundred
specimen a hundred percent against the
rt-pcr so the this one could also work
in urine but we hope this thing can
eventually get out quickly into the
market can be used for our current
ongoing outbreak and of course mostly so
far all the method has been focused on a
molecular diagnosis as you can see there
are you know for the molecular tests you
have to divide into two step first the
nucleus an imprecation technology then
of course the detection or
identification technology so for the
application technology so far the
real-time PCR is the one that widely
used so um then of course people also
use a multiplex PCR and also use a mem
or tsukada isothermal application
technology like the one you recently
just cleared by FDA the average test
their use so called the near isothermal
application methods so there can
it had amplified very quickly within
minutes that you can get results then of
comfort identification technology yeah
again it's also uses the real time
because real time means the application
and the detection happens simultaneously
so attachment problems the one wisely
widely use right now now people also use
next-gen sequencing microarray even
started using CRISPR the you know the
gene targeting the the editing tools for
the identification technology so so far
the targets and the location you know
people has been used the and the M or
the the polymerase operating frame genes
targets then also uses the single
targets or multiple targets then some of
the master not only can detect it then
can identify what type of all the kind
of the tornavoz it is then of course for
the real-time PCR they also have support
of quantification capacity so that not
only detail here but also can give the
member of the viral load so at the time
our presentation they're happy quite a
few of the methods has been cleared so
those are the methods molecular mass has
been cleared by the China FDA and as you
can see both of them are based on real
time PCR only cup of them a pesar is a
next-gen sequencing or personality are
some application followed by Michael Ray
then of course in the United States we
have FDA has something called emergency
use authorization and that have cleared
quite a few of those of course the list
is keep going on okay so I just this the
one that clear the last week you can
honestly they're over almost 20 of those
again both of them as indicated by
Centers for Disease Control prevention
they are based on the real-time pcr
methods and currently there are two
methods that has been labeled
so-called upon a care why is the Saviour
expert Express sauce cover a to test
they otherwise something just cleared a
couple days ago on by a bird this is not
this effort ever the so called them now
the based on isomer technology both
technology can be done in the final care
site you know from 15 to 45 minutes okay
so after the molecular test there's
another method now have been widely used
at the Lisa T in China the serology
tests that's the test you can't use for
anybody test one of the reason that
geology has been used widely in China is
because at the very early stage the
nucleus it some of the nucleic acid a
method has not been performed very well
for a lot of reasons I will talk about
later apart so that's the reason people
has been used rapid Sorority test for
the detection of the anybody's as you
can see from this you know published
article then the people developed a very
quick panic here better flu based in USA
to detect IgM and IgG memories that can
be done within 15 minutes at their time
their cram their can reach sensitivity
of 89% when the specimen halls are
pretty good against the PCR and of
course pulls the finger sticker and when
blood specimen can be used for this kind
of test
so yeah because of that they're quite a
few of the Serg test has been cleared by
China FDA some of those you can do that
in the high throughput use a machine
some others can be done as in in the
field
like many of protocol without
instruments so but but so far of course
you know the most of this has an e had
analytical data and they are needing
more and more accurate data to to see
their real clinical performance so so
that's yet about analytic part now we
come to the very important part that's a
process analytical part so what do we
have so far learned about that nuclear a
cd-based technology and we know we
should avoid any method that do not have
internet venture yes because especially
for the or offenders pass correction how
do you know that the specimen was
collected right how do you know you get
into the right spot
you have the sohara housekeeping gene
detected how do you know there is no
inhibitors in there so ok so yes you
want to have a device that make sure
there's internal control including there
then the second one you need avoid the
device that only cover single target
because we now know that you know
although it's not as bad as in friends
of ours but this bills us over to Mars
did us continue to change so hot a new
mutate so if you're only popular one
target there can be a specific target
for carnival for SAS poverty so that
means if the virus start meeting then
your test will become useless so for
that reason we need avoid device the
economy cover one single
pocket so yeah in contrast the preferred
device should have one but you'll have a
two or three specifically targets you
can one internal control so if that's
the case in this situation usually you
have a one target that's a so-called
relatively a beta carniverous as Janis
specific and then of course we plus
another one that's the assassin over to
visor specific then of course for the
the nucleic acid test you need to make
sure you don't do not have false
negatives and results that's because we
do not collect right the specimen type
farmer right time that discriminates
then of course another very big
interpretation of the results is you
have to have a penance between the
nuclei see the results and anybody
results right now we still do not have a
rapid antigen test yet as you know
because produce high affinity good
anybody mostly male anybody to SAS cover
to Mars technically real time so so far
we only have nucleic acid methods and
anybody test and as you know those two
tests are different things so talk about
nucleic acid test this remains the test
or choice for infection the other words
for accurate infection detection or
diagnosis you need to choose nucleus at
the best essay and when you choose the
nucleus reverses and it was the early
stage you try to use uh presbury
specimens okay in a later stage you use
the lower espada specimens or GI tract
specimens then for the pre-analytical
factors you need to be a very
significant you know pay attention to
like you know you know where you crack
the specimen
when you click the specimen so make sure
you click specialist right time in the
right fight as we just point out at any
time then of course for the false
positive specimens because you know
depend on what are kind of massively use
let's say if you use the real-time PCR
you are carried over contamination to
generate a false positive result this
limited you know but it's not minimized
okay it's a limited but if you use the
so called a three-stage we've extracted
then you put it into application then
you start another you know like a
microwave or something else application
or authentication
that's your carryover contamination or
false positive rate is high then
remember serology isn't on test but it's
all about hose response so that means it
is indirect retrospective detect the
infection so it we are not work in the
early stage of the infection so you
cannot use throughout your test to
diagnose of accurate infection and of
course but they're working habitus which
need to be conformed serology could be
used in confirmation of SAS Kovach
infection based on you know IgM antibody
or colloidal IgG antibody titres well I
have to emphasize here you know so far
there are so many literature's or the
you know the so-called high level
physicians talk about a favor the
serology tests I just want you know
please pay attention tools because the
technology-wise summer so far the
serology tests we used a lot of energies
are not that purified some of these
antigens actually farm
other like pharmacist or murse previous
studies okay so as you can imagine if
you don't have a source who were to
specific energy purified then those are
your anybody could have because reacted
so at the very beginning you probably
you say yeah I can detect IgM much
earlier that could be a cross where
reaction to some other classic you know
sauce infections and it's in the latest
stage as you also know the serology
tests could cause a lot of the so called
the false positive reaction and like in
autoimmune disease or woman in pregnancy
and this kind of situation especially
IgM anybody detection this is a very i
GM tests notorious for false positive
results okay
I've been talking about the other data
into appreciation now I also want to
briefly talk about but what kind of
tests that we use for cure
what part of Testament we you know we'll
use for an infection control so yeah
nowadays we you know we also want test
the nucleus a test in vector swab so we
film if we didn't test the you could
asset from the GI and if the patient
without symptoms this beauty the
procedure of a cure and if it detected
them usually considered lectures and
also the patient probably still not
completely cured yet but anyway so there
are a lot of hiking going on here yeah
how many times need to detect the
consecutively in a storm before you can
release the patient or this you know
patient out from isolation and this kind
of sense so anyway we text all time and
Dana
to confirm those so another thing is
that we need to talk about is the Barlow
as you know most of the nucleus to the
test offensive about on the real-time
PCR can we use the VAR load that is
generated by the real-time PCR for
monitoring the answer so far is probably
yes there are quite a few papers come
out from you know literature that
indicates when the patient getting
better the treatments are getting better
than the vial of the getting they don't
detect it or getting lower
this not only happens in the a
prospective specimen without a specimen
stool specimen but also happens in the
saliva specimen as well so people have
been thinking about this use this to
monitor this and that one theta then I
did not list here is their funded you
know the people other people like the
you know people immune comprised can
hide a higher bar low then they regular
people and also the Mahabharata is a
sushi with severe severity of disease
and also the violence is associated with
the cd4 cell counts but all these things
probably eventually could be used for
monitoring the disease treatment you can
see but anyway we will continue wash as
tangles so that's it about to this talk
so I know I still have a couple minutes
I want to cover what's the future
direction so for the future direction as
you know the ideal diagnostic assay
would be like this
so in the central lab this will be the
si can cover high server so right now
can right now you know in like a
male-male lab they can cover thousands
or ten thousand specimen a day by
so-called
is your protest and on the other side in
the doctor's office or in the front then
you know you can use a state testing you
know people be centralized location
support a point of care test you can't
give the result very quickly and without
generating any trouble in the site of
course you know when you do this you
need to make sure all these instruments
there can run those tests are available
worldwide
you don't want the people by your kit
and also have to buy your instruments
and then your device and of course the
other good test that not only can for
tiny ocu's can also for infection
control for the monitor angels so you
want you have a test not only for treat
but also for isolation and also for
monitor this kind of sense so we feel
the world a method that we have been
just come out from a Cepheid it's called
a Cepheid expert express SAS Cobra 2 si
could Fitness needs it is simple is very
accurate it's a rapid and it is safe
so it's you know coming to the together
is become a sauce so we have a power
tool can you know to against a sauce so
hopefully these things will be used in
the current situation and can fire joint
the fine thing okay so that's it for my
talk I will stop here thank you very
much thank you dr. Tang for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen let's get started what is
emergency use authorization
yes emergency use authorization is a new
regulation way tool that the US FDA that
just did we'll start from 2009 when the
n1 it h1n1 friends autocorrect happens
this means when you have a new virus or
new pathogen come out you do not have
any standard you can't use to compare
your new device to them so that fds a
yeah go ahead a dual one there's not
analytical meditation then you can
submit it we proven use in a clinical
situation and after that you crack the
data and submit it back to the US FDA I
can then USF pierre get a cleared so
that's the way people you know can back
the things going on so this is a time
that yes FDA to the same thing for the
sauce cover to revamp its great question
and thank you for your answer dr. ting
our next question is can POC t-tests be
done by non laboratory staff yeah the
Poincare test actually um means any kind
of test can be done in the location of
the care that it could be tested by you
know this lab staff what could it be
detected by non lab staff so that's
depending on the situation in the u.s.
regulation by FDA
there's caught a Creole she under clear
there is a one category of the test hot
clear waived so those are indicates
tests are very simple can be done easily
you know without a lot of skills so
those are the test can be done by say
for example by the physician or nurse
you don't have to test those by naps
so those are called clear and wave test
so this is the part of the a point of
care test than everyone looking for but
again not every point of care test can
be done by you know down that staff in
the lab great thank you again dr. Tang
we're going to wrap up with this last
question it's how do would you diagnose
co-infection of Koba 19 and other common
respiratory pathogens this is a great
question arm as you know at this time
especially for the cover for the south
cup of wine are two very all to break
the reason we can see it seems so
complicated because we just have you
know this one sticker together with
influenza and now we also sum up the
place also stick with I sleep with
Patrice incisional infection so yes
during this time not army you have to
make sure you take it for the patient
sick from the stars covered to infection
but also if that patient is suffered
from the other common respiratory
infections like influenza like you know
ice being so what we can do there are
quite a few methods can be used to do
this while those we call it's a syndrome
testing so you can have a panel of the
Maliki test then they can cover all the
common in counted pathogens and this
including in flames are neutrally summer
typical you know the ammonia causing
bacteria Slyke a micro plasma and not
collie including sarcoma too so you can
we see you know minutes or hours you can
you know decide it would kind of the
patient's infection the patient will
suffer great pain great questions thank
you again dr. Tang for your time today
and your import
research before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration but this
webcast can be viewed on-demand
through the end of 2020 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues you may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye